[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we're
backstage at American Idol where Katy
Perry
aka Snow White had a bit of a rage
moment tonight when she finds out that
her favorite contestant might be
interested in someone else was there an
image of someone drifting through your
head as you were singing that possibly
yeah yeah
[Applause]
let's just say Shane
I saw someone in the lounge no
[Applause]
and they were talking about Kade maybe
having a lady friend and it's apparently
a fellow contestant so is that you
Sunday nights to find out no comment
what do you like about Kate he's just
some of them in the camera cut to Gabby
and I want to ask you about what's going
on there Kate
well I mean honest to goodness either
we're great friends we are good friends
I adore her and adore her I do I adore
and we are but we are trying to build a
career and we're focused and we're
hard-working and we're not letting it
get in the way and we're just trying to
stay focused iLike his face I like I
like his hair and how curly it is when
he sings Kirti
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]